each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
okay it's my great pleasure to introduce
than your crowning I mean he was a I
think most of us know him I mean he did
a lot of influential work the similar
model checker he did a lot of work on
decision procedures is the author of a
procedure book that's using many CS
departments now he he was a postdoc
fetch Clark he moved to Switzerland and
now he's in Oxford and next week is
going to present her interesting paper
about floating points at the zoo
procedure for floating point numbers but
should a is when she talked about model
checking of concurrent systems please
hey Thank You Alan are you at FM cat
Africa yes I can begin my presentation
on conference offered by sales talk
advertising my presentation oration my
students presentation at FM cat next
week's monday in austin ok so the sales
all is going to continue so i'm going to
sell you tools to model check current
software ok so the motivation for this
would be clear and i'm going to be very
fast image is actually part of this
presentation because all of you are very
motivated about bugs in software general
in concurrent software in particular let
me just clarify what form of concurrency
I'm after because there is enough
concurrency going around that this term
concurrent software is making them
biggest enough okay so you could for
example thing about programs that
communicate via some form of message
passing or something like this over the
network as being some form of concurrent
software but what I am mostly after is
shareable concurrency so something you
get from say using the windows 42 Fred
API ok so for romo let me clarify that
there are two forms of concurrency will
usually consider servers synchronous
concurrency which you normally find in
very low level systems they either
hardware level or maybe an embedded
control software and then there's a
synchronous concurrency which is what
you would normally find a
in what is called concurrent software
running on the commodity operating
systems such as Windows okay and also
software it communicates we are network
is usually necessarily asynchronous
because it is simply difficult to get a
synchrony over distributed system okay
there is a straightforward way of
formalizing this and it's also worth
while doing so just very briefly in
order to clarify the difference between
synchronous and asynchronous concurrency
so in general we assume that there is a
transition relation and this transition
relation would describe the behavior of
a particular Fred I and we will write T
and X I for this transition relation ok
we can also partition of the state into
the park with this something is used by
particular Fred and here in this case we
assuming that there are something like n
freud's ok The Oval transition relation
of the system is then simply the
conjunction of these individual
transition systems in the synchronous
case and in the asynchronous case you
vols usually see some sort of scheduling
decision this means somebody say an
operating system scheduler a piece of
code decides which Fred's gets to
execute and the one way to model
business by simply save exists on choice
of the Fred I and when this particular
transition relation of this particular
Fred gets invoked and this Fred makes a
transition on the left side di is s
times s I but yes is the product of s 1
to s n so it includes SI also right yeah
do so business miss transition relation
so we this is to say very coming from ok
so we're current state and this is the
next state the reason why it's s times s
I is the photos when you have for
synchronous transition system you can
modify only your part of state space
usually right so that's why it's si but
you can read everything ok so it's not
actually type of so so this is a ver for
you transition relation of your
particular Friday's s times s I but
since these are conjoined went I estates
basic unless you get written in
transition okay and in case of
asynchronous concurrency you would
normally assume that a fried can modify
everything ok so that's why it's s times
s so if you want you can also have you
could also have private stay here and
make it clear by just adding your si
here and then you would add a constraint
here but says that the private set of
all the other Fred's does not change so
that's one way of ok if I miss but I
didn't do this because it wouldn't
really fit nicely over the slides
anymore and in general there are systems
where Fred can really change his eye
yeah what question this is break it
looks like for me on the left side we
have synchronous right clearly you can
model hardware like that oh yes is there
any kind of programming model for
software alignment that is yes there are
plenty of programming models in software
focus so there is an interesting
cultural artifact here with respect to
this so since I've been doing lots of
teaching in all sorts of countries all
over the world I observe the following
so if you talk to an America and
undergrad or grad student or and you
asking about concurrency is they will
normally describe something like this
habeas the scheduler and you get some
choice of a Fred and but does something
and we have a fried waits in the
meantime okay and but if you on the
other hand grab a French academic or
person who comes from a French academic
background then if you swim would
concurrency so it will give you this
description ok and in this sort of
environment we sort of synchronous
programming English is also much more
known ok one particular effect office
was a falling so I taught a course on
software on verification general at
Carnegie Mellon University and it's
caramel universities of one homework
assignment was model something like an
elevator in sav ok and now smv by nature
is this ok so it's a synchronous
language we have a clear notion of a
transition and various no such thing
there is really fried szoke so smv has a
processes on top of this which is just
simply simulated by having a fred
selector verbal but native vs MV is a
synchronous language and the students
we're simply not able to deal with
the synchronous programming environment
so the idea of it but two variables
change at the same time was completely
alien to them okay all right so for this
talk we gonna focus on this case and
it's important but it's viscous and we
are things like is Esther in like that
so yes so there are languages in in this
real more French embedded systems design
languages that would fit in the
synchronous development framework okay
but for whatever reason they are not
that well-known in India's for example
or actually anywhere out of outside of
France yeah I don't ask me okay so so as
I said we're going to focus on
asynchronous share variable concurrency
so so no message is being passed but
global variables being written and this
effect is visible to all threads okay so
i usually give a bit of a motivational
story about this but i guess here at
microsoft this is not necessary to do
that okay so there is a physical
argument as to why this makes some sense
and that relates to power consumption in
in CPU design so my actual educational
background is on hardware so I did my
PhD on processor verification so it's
why i like this entire discussion right
and it will be happy if you discuss
low-level details of processors if you
want it but it's not really the point
here in this presentation so one picture
found recently is this this is doing a
very quick shop at illustrating this so
this shows relationship between
frequency which rises miracle here on
this axis and the power consumption
meaning current drawn by the chip when
you go up and so one thing you see here
is that this is clearly nonlinear okay
so risk elite is some sort of quadratic
relationship here right so this means by
wed by lowering your frequency is just a
little bit you can get very significant
savings in power okay and so one
effective business that you can now buy
CPUs that have a hundred cores okay and
this particular vendor at alero he
actually promises that you can run an
operating system on each of one of these
fully feature on us so each one of these
has cash level 1 cache and a level 2
cache separately and they're connected
by means of some sort of switch and they
share address space okay so another
thing which is probably not necessary to
point out to any great length here in
this audience is that once you have
asynchronous concurrency and friday in
the leavings and very weird things can
happen the result your program shows
obviously depends on what are au shoes
okay so we have a brief animation here
so if your first executed for at one and
then the obverse you get a particular
state in which X is 11 and why ends up
being 21 and if you choose some
alternative one when it's obvious
trivial and you can end up and get
another state okay so that's for this
audience here shouldn't be anything of a
surprise so you say Journal that your
program has a race and now again a
little bit of a story about education so
when you talk to hardcore academics it
will tell you how so you should have
used locks to make the program rice free
ok but then obviously any engineer will
tell you about races are great and we
must have them and that's how we get
performance and and race free software
is really bad inheritance and a good
story where I'm being told there but on
this question of races and software's by
an IBM engineer he used as an example an
embedded medical device where you have a
thread that measures the patient's
temper temper ature computes it for
example by by measuring the length
between two signals ok and then there's
another thread that's responsible for
the GUI and you definitely want these to
be two separate threads because the GUI
is obviously not important as
temperature measurement ok and so we had
ears but they communicate here some
share variable and the fret that
measures the temperature just write it
and the Fred wit dis place it just reads
it from home they shared variable ok and
obviously no you don't care which one
you read do you read the one of the last
measurement of the 104 current
measurement so if they are micro second
apart the user who stares at the display
will not be able to tell ok so the
program is full of races and it
obviously the result depends in some
sense on the schedule but not in a
practical
okay so that's why you were happy for a
program to have a race okay bye-bye the
race wouldn't go away even if you put a
lock around it it doesn't make any
difference it's still the same brace
okay so another thing which I'm going to
ignore it obviously the question of
low-level memory models so there's a lot
of research on this going on in my group
but I'm not going to cover it in this
presentation so this is Intel assembly
and is there let me try to make a survey
who cannot read this here okay so
Moscone who can not okay who can read
this here okay so are people who were
okay fine so the bouillon bouillon
property is set its sights everybody can
read with you so when you probably also
heard already but so Intel obviously
doesn't guarantee you that these move
statements are in any sense atomic and
if you start out this program with
Wiesel's memory cells x and y been be
initialized with zero you would sort of
hope that that you end up with ones on
there but unfortunately this little
piece of code may terminate the all
registers EA x and e bx still being zero
which is obviously bad news for us ok so
again a few rotations answer could be oh
yeah you just have to add a memory
barrier or friends everywhere and the
engineers answer is going to be that you
don't really want fish because these
fences are horribly expensive okay and
so when one of the things I'm working on
is a tool that would try to identify
locations are you only very really
really need as as opposed to location so
you don't really really need this okay
sorry a memory fence is simply something
that would synchronize the various
course to a point that you can guarantee
that they have a consistent view of the
memory so it's a Stetson reza hardware
feature that's provided by Intel okay
unfortunately it's expensive in the
sense that it takes a long time to
execute much much much longer than the
actual store operation so if you if you
have a simplicity point of view that oh
you're just going to insert a fence
after every instruction with potentially
modify is shared memory when you're poor
Graham is going to be a hundred X slower
24 now so it's not a very good answer
okay so another thing which is likely
going to need very little introduction
is boolean programs given that I'm here
okay so i don't i deleted the slides
that actually introduce how these are
being produced is this a fair assumption
that you've heard of a boolean program
story before from somebody here okay I
see some nodding okay so this new part
of the story is here in slide I online
night okay so I'm assuming since I want
to verify programs that may use a
variable concurrency but I'm going to
deal with concurrent boolean programs
and this means i need some new statement
that will produce the thread and I just
invented a new statement to extend the
syntax of reese pooda burbs and I call
it start Fred ok so it works like a
go-to in a boolean program so it takes a
list of program locations this argument
and it in some sense branches non little
mini aesthetically to all of these but
each one of these branches is going to
be done by a new Fred ok so this fred
inherits the local state from its parent
so all the local variables say b4 b5 b6
b7 here get copied before when you fred
is spawn off ok and they obviously share
a view of the global state ok these
variables be home to be free here and
then the the semantics is such that the
the assignment statements that are in
the Buddha program are going to be
atomic and where it's going to be an
asynchronous interleaving between these
statements that's the semantics of
boolean programs and I I first heard I
don't need to formalize for serious
audience and it would be straight
forward to so to do so ok
so the difference is that the global
state is shared between all threats so
all threads see the same values we won't
be to be free so phone threat modified
they belong this is immediately visible
and all the other threads okay whereas
if you modify the 45 p 6 or b7 you only
modify your own copy all right so
technically you can think of these
variables being on on some separate
piece of memory that's private to each
one of his friends few thinking is that
you need to start thread within the
scope of this local declaration
tendering that you create additional
copies yes you every time you do a
surfer you create a copy of these
variables and and the value of these
variables is guaranteed to be that of
your parents at the time to create the
friend okay but once you refer this
creator you can start changing them and
this will not affect the value of these
variables in your parent all right so
this is maybe slightly different from
what you would see in a programming
language like C where start Fred would
only give you a private piece of stack
for those things you put on the stack
after creating a fret ok so i'm not
making this distinction here between
after you create the thread and before
you create a thread this is not too much
of a practical problem because in c you
can actually only access variables that
are on somewhere deeper in the stack if
you had a pointer to it ok and these
sort of variables would anyway not be
modeled with boolean variables that are
in the local scope ok it's an easy way
to pass parameters
oh yes that's could be used for this if
you wanted to write to pass some
parameters to a fight with your crating
okay again it's not normally used like
this because the way you normally pass
parameters to a fred is by giving it a
pointer which points to some designated
data structure for it contains these
parameters now and this data structure
is normally dynamically allocated so it
happens outside of the scope of these
boolean variables all right yeah so
there's one more extension which is
actually not on the slide so one thing
you definitely need is the following so
you need variables with global scope at
a Fred local ok so you need variables
that would be up here I should probably
others to the slide say a variable B 1
which is syntactically global but
semantically Fred local ok this is says
all it's not just specific de Bouillon
programs but this has also been
recognized by the people who define the
ansi c standard and the c++ iso standard
because the new version of the c++
standard is going to have a keyword Fred
local which is going to do exactly that
so and I'm also invented i'm also adding
this keyword to the boolean programming
language if you want and has exactly
same meaning as the same keyword in in
c++ yes they enforce that Fred local by
some kind of a dynamic or static
checking no I mean the expectation is
that the runtime environment of your
system provides that guarantee but this
variable that your mark is being fried
local is actually going to be Fred local
oh I see so you try to access it which
they way they get their own copy they'll
get a copy yes they get their own each
one of them sees go and coffee so you
can have two Fred's read by different
values into these Fred local variables
and and they will not see each other's
modifications you're already using this
without knowing it so for example in c
you have all these global data
structures right so for example local
time returns actually a global data
structure you have a number of these
capi to IP a cold sweat that have been
invented long time before Fred existed
and they made a little hack fair to make
it appear that you can still use these
our interference between Fred's okay
your semantics is also going to be that
different threats get different copies
yes just like you know just like for
remoteness like recursive procedures get
different copies of the same years
variable declaration okay right so you
really need to distinguish local scope
from being Fred local so that's why this
work local and global here is really
dangerous because it makes the scope and
visibility with respect to what the
frets two and one just needs to be more
precise than one says local okay does it
mean local scope does it mean Fred local
and the same thing with global alright
so these are the two things I'm throwing
into the mix which you haven't seen
before so I have a Starfighter command
and they have is this attribute for a
verbal that makes it that makes it Fred
local even though its global scope ok
and the use of this is simply to to map
these existing programming language
constructs with existing programs
already use into this world all right so
when the next fashion that you ask is ok
ok we are doing these boolean programs
these concurrent boolean programs come
from and you know how do we do the usual
business of predicate refinement and so
on and the answer is actually but you
don't have to do anything so the box
where computer abstraction needs trivial
changes like you need something that
creates a start for a command ok and
something that keeps track of Fred local
global scope variables ok so just keep a
flag for vista and then generate the
keyword when you need it so it's a very
modest change you need in this
attraction we find a group ok the good
news is that you can essentially use
this loop as is in the concurrent
setting abstraction happens as before
with this minor change simulation is as
before the only thing to take care of is
to use this fred interleaving from your
abstract counter example and refinement
also happens as before ok the only thing
where you really need to worry about is
how you're going to model check these
concurrent boolean programs ok let's
essentially it so here we have a stupid
example of a sea program that really
needs a load of context which is before
it
gets to this violation of this assertion
okay so it's it's clear but that here
these two threads need to cooperate in
order to get where so to pass vizcarra
this Fred needs to set g21 and then to
get past that guard that for it needs to
set g two to two and then to get past
this card this threatens to set G to
free ok this is obviously a schedule you
would never ever get on a real system
because it's just way too unlikely but
at least in theory yes it does exist and
interleaving what gets you a violation
of this assertion ok so this is what the
main program could look like you just
have to call soupy fourth grade or if
you want to think of a VIN 42 equivalent
office I probably should make a slide
for that ok so um this is what the
boolean program for this could look like
ok so initially you could maybe start
out with a predicate vicious as G is
equal to 4 and the abstraction for
business also straightforward ok and the
only thing that may be new is that you
have a start Fred command here and your
main procedure which corresponds to
these P Fred create calls ok so you give
this to your model checker and for now
assume we have one that model checks
with sort of programs and your model
checker is going to do what it going to
give you a counter example and it's
likely going to be very trivial because
all it really needs to do is it needs to
execute this statement which you can do
right away because it just can run past
B's nondeterministic guards here ok and
then just execute this assertion here ok
so there's only one Fred switch really
needed to get a counter example on this
abstraction all right so this is how
this could look like so suppose you had
a model checker it gives you a counter
example trace which begins up here and
whenever I use see one of these
horizontal lines here first Fred switch
in the counter example from your model
checker for the abstract model ok so you
can see you really only need two
switches to get to violate this
assertion ok so you can then do your
usual simulation this just means that
you collect constraints from the
original program in some if you want
static single assignment form and you
actually it's together by means of a big
conjunction okay and you give this to
say set free and obviously the problem
here is that you will get this back say
this is not really a trace on the
original program okay so but the next
thing that will happen is you can give
this to your refinement procedure and
your refined procedure will add more
product gets on to you of all these
predicates full of these cards and in
total you need four iterations you need
these for predicate switch any
refinement Aristocles not a really
rocket science here and then you will
just get a more elaborate version of
this counter example here it has all
these four switches that you need and
when your simulation will pass and you
actually do have a counter example where
it jumps back and forth between these
two friends so this is a demo I I like
to give to students very I actually show
them in in in their programming
environment at race with hops back and
forth between these two threads and gets
to the violated assertion okay so that's
not too complicated and all we really
needed for this was a model checker for
this concurrent boolean programs alright
so what I'm going to present from now on
is just worrying about that and the
value you get from Vista so in some
sense product abstraction helps you to
disentangle some complexity sources here
so we get rid of things like integers or
pointers and so on and we can actually
focus on on the current currency aspect
of this problem okay and I'm going to
become a little bit more formal from
this point on alright so what I'm going
to consider is a composition of n
replicated communicating threats all of
them run the same program so clear why
I'm running the same program end times I
mean there's just one program and even
though the threads might have different
behavior we're just may be executing
different pieces of the same program
right so that's why it's n replicated
copies of the same program and that's
important ok so if i had n different
programs the story would be
fundamentally different so it's
important that i have n copies of the
same program right as i said so we're
shared variables these can be read and
written by x over Fred's
and there is local wearables local in
the sense of being threadlocal not local
scope okay very they have one copy per
Fred and this is invisible and
inaccessible to the arbor frets and
that's also important if you change wet
when the entire story again changes okay
so this is just to clarify some some
notation here will stage is a vector
that consists of some part that's shared
s okay and then there n different
versions of the local state la12 ln okay
and so we whenever i'm going to talk
about local state i'm just going to
write l index I for the local state of
Fred I right now we're comes another
concept which is very important and that
is the concept of a Fred state ok now
think yourself of being a friend ok you
always wanted to be a program like Tron
right right so you have Fred what it is
what is it you can see right what is it
what tron can see when Tron looks around
in this world okay Tron can see the
shared state and its own local state ok
you're unable to see the local set of
anybody else's so some pair of s and
some li is what you can see you as with
being a Fred I ok so that's also it's a
very important concept here ok we now
define formally what problem we are
trying to solve so given such a pair as
el dozer exists a reachable global state
such that L is Li for some I ok so does
there exist a reachable global
configuration such as a particular Fred
state exists in there and this is
obviously a projection out of this big
vector alright so at this point i
usually get some comments of a forum hey
isn't this restrictive and aren't you
losing something here in terms of xpress
ability and says you aren't really you
can do many things obviously any single
index properties of Fred's you can
specify this way anything that just
talks about month Fred but you can also
write properties that talk about
multiple threads by adding monitors ok
for example if you care to write a
mutual exclusion
which is actually property about the
entire state vector you can simply
rewrite this by adding a monitor which
just watches but mutually exclusive
mutual exclusivity is being preserved
okay so whenever you enter the shared
section you would just set the share
variable to true and then you leave with
your set it to false and you just write
an assertion that says that the shared
variable is over it is false whenever
you're about to enter it okay this way
you have rewritten the global property
into a local one okay yes please pretty
good abstraction I mean it's if the game
is to really analyze we implementation
of programs right not like textbooks
algorithms and yes or I mean when do you
really have a situation a realistic
situation where all the processes of the
threads are you in that you well the
trick is simply as follows right so you
know in a real log rhythmic setting you
could for example a situation which you
argue about you have a device driver and
that's really one program but there
multiple instances running of it okay
you are going to talk about or will you
have vision and abstraction scheme for
instance that could take processes right
start are different you not strike them
in such a way that you would match oh
yeah that's very very easy night yes
assumption there but the one where your
previous five yes because he doesn't
handle even the motivating example that
you had earlier in the top right right
so so that's that's key really right so
this is actually but it's actually very
easy to achieve all you need to do is be
phoning so you could for example use
local state in order to make the Fred
that you start distinguish what it's
doing ok another thing to realize here
is that the start Fred command can
actually be used in multiple locations
so there can be more than one ok this
means you can actually for each Fred
where you create you could have a
separate start Fred command that jumps
to a different control location so the
usual scenario in which you have say
different procedures for each one of
your frets this fits very well in here
alright so and that's simulate able the
fist model of
computation without any effort at all
the matching country example that you
get to build oh no no no you get exactly
the sequence of control flow locations
where you expect to get so this is not
complicated at all I saw that you just
say that man I have two threads that's
kind of different states yes you can
abstract them in non deterministic
fashion and everything both start Andrew
you can make you 30 minutes ago I should
ask you I will show you how to make mr.
the monistic so one thing you can do is
one thing you actually exploit here is
the fact that it's asynchronous
concurrency it's a subtle point but it's
important that the concurrency is
asynchronous if you use this in a
synchronous setting it wouldn't work
anymore okay so you know something about
the initial state say that all the
variables are a zero or something like
this when a Fred start executing and
this Fred will then try to find out what
it's supposed to be doing ok and it just
simply looks at the global state and say
counts up a counter which you can build
with boolean variables if you want say a
unary encoding ok when it decides I'm
Fred zeros I'm going to run procedure a
ok and then the next fredward starts
running sees that the count is already
at one and says okay I'm supposed to be
executing procedure be ok so even though
all of these programs all of his Fred
start out executing the same piece of
code they can in fact deterministically
execute separate procedures ok and all
you've added is bone statement at the
very beginning of your program so it's
you're really not losing anything by
saying that these are identical
procedures that are being executed by
all threads it's it's not a restriction
at all it doesn't cause any including
complexity or recount examples aren't
getting a more complicated anything of
that sort yeah so it's a no pain
translation ok and in fact we actually
do it in the in the model checker for
the boolean program itself so the
counter example it comes out of the
model checker looks exactly the way you
expect it to look like all right now
actually I'm going to iterate on this
point since all these replicas defects
Fred execute the same program ok one
thing you will notice is on
lot of redundancy in the States but you
explore this okay we remember we also
have shared and in local state space
right which is this s here for the
shared space and then I use these upper
case letters A and B for states over
these local variables all right so now
one thing to remember is all the
variables of boolean ok so this means
whereas no such thing as a fright ID
that can float around there you only
have boolean variables ok and that but
in particular means that it's actually
irrelevant what Fred number of fred is
ok so you can't really distinguish
redbone from Fred to there's no way we
can tell which one where r ok so in
particular if you think about the case
of for freds and suppose you have two
threads in state a and two Fred's in
state B ok when you could just as well
say that various the same state in which
you first have boobies and then the A's
or first to be event ways I'm going to
be e ok all of these from point of view
of the semantics and behavior of the
system are completely indistinguishable
you can actually prove this you can make
a formal argument but if you reorder
these threads at any time during your
exploration you will get exactly the
same set of virtual states at the end ok
cause a loss of information at all to
shuffle these friends around it's not an
over approximation that's important okay
so um which means this model exists
exhibit some kind of specific symmetry
here ok yeah it is for me five for it so
it sounded interested in a managed that
can make basically non symmetric system
symmetric or I by we ever using
or using some deterministic behavior
where you each thread individually will
be able to access is read this counter
yes that tells how many threats are in
that state etc but that's break the
symmetry but I know it doesn't but if
you have two threads the first one sees
the counter and there's Oh nobody has a
start let us proceed your air the second
season yes yes well I have seen you
cancel at any point in time swap with
two without having lost anything but
when you think that's relevant is how
many are in that particular state but
not which one is the first and which one
is the second okay along the same lines
if you think sometimes programs new
years to thread identified right with
some unique and I think I case it's just
part of the steady so I mean his story
whole town it just means that those
states would not be the same but do you
have like to pay and be communicating
and then you define a plus B pile a plus
B and then you get some symmetry but
have a much bigger stake space at the
end so because you have known both so I
don't know but I let you go so the claim
I want you to believe at this point is
that I can shuffle my state vector
arbitrarily and I'm not losing
information and then I'm not adding
behavior so that's something you would
believe at this point okay i just sort
these okay not an over approximation not
another approximation and that's because
various no such thing as a Fred number
where you can access ok right so um the
idea is fair for fairly straightforward
what we are going to do and that's
something called counter abstraction ok
and it's a bit dangerous to use this
term because this term is has been used
for many different things so this is a
little big Locker fee of five years that
have been floating around in order to do
this sort of symmetry reduction restore
counter abstraction comes from this
paper here so the PIAT believe it's been
lately and they use a very specific kind
of counter abstraction in which way
truncate counters once they exceed the
value 1 so we distinguish of a case in
the sure where 0 frets in a particular
state 1 fret in a particular State or
arbitrarily many threads in a particular
state ok that's obviously in over
approximation as soon as you say where
you don't really track how many threads
on a per click particular state then you
use information because it's maybe
important that only two okay so the key
thing here is we are not doing that we
are keeping these counters precisely as
we are we never lose any information
about them okay no over approximation no
wonder proxy may shun versus precise
technique yeah
that's going to be the second part of
the talk would it be acceptable for you
if I postpone the package insert so the
credit assumption is the current
assumption is that there's some number
in safe or in this okay but
there's going to be a second part of the
floor ferme asking what if n was
unbounded right so for now um what I'm
assuming is that I can represent my set
of states as follows that was just keep
track of some shared state and then I'm
counting how many frets are in a
particular local state okay these
counters are never truncated or anything
of that sort so what I'm claiming is
that up to with symmetric permutation
this is producing the exact same set of
states all right yeah so now this is so
nice but it's all something you can
least argue is anticipated by the
literature now where's our contribution
and there are two things here these are
all very technical so it's not of new
free radical idea it's it's a low-level
programming implementation type of idea
okay so let me start with the obvious
one so then you have these sort of
vectors here and you count the local you
count how many fights are in your local
state okay so essentially what you do is
for every conceivable local state you
keep a counter so voluntary contribution
is the maid is that we say okay we
observe that there may be many local
states if you think about a boolean
program we are a 2 to the power of K
local states where k is the number of
local variables that's a lot okay so if
you have 50 predicates you have 2 to the
power 50 local states actually times the
number of program locations because the
program counter is also part of local
state so there's just way too many so in
one easy observation you can make is
that if there are n fred's then there at
most n of these counters that are
nonzero ok so if I've for fred's this
means at most for Congress have a
nonzero value but if I have a billion
encounters possibly this means pretty
much all of them are going to be 0
so one obvious optimization you can make
is that you meet all of these zero value
counters from your state representation
and this gets the complexity of these
procedures down from n to the power of
lvls the size of the local state space
to the minimum of N and L okay and the
thing here is that the number of fred's
ends to be much smaller than the size of
your local state space yes please I'm
not sure if it's really that
that's some form of encoding yes so
you'll meet you you have you say how
many we have in principle you have all
locations yes then you say how many
locations your skin yes so think of a
matrix and you just want to represent
the nonzero values because it's it's
very sparse ok that's the idea ok so
it's not the terribly deep idea but
interestingly if you look at the
existing tools all of them will expect
input very explicitly list all the local
states in a file right and they
explicitly build the set of local states
so there's nothing where you could
there's no existing tool where you could
just go ahead and translate a boolean
program into because the translation is
already exponential all right yeah so
you need to get rid of its you only need
to you only want to store create and
talk about local states that are in some
sense in use and obvious you need to do
this on the fly without actually
translating a pudding program into that
because you don't know up front what
logo states are going to be reachable at
what point all right so another little
trick is and that's actually related to
this is obviously you need to put these
counters in the context of a particular
instruction all right because when you
look at a particular piece of code in
your building program you you actually
really know exactly what it's doing and
you can tell which counters are possibly
modified all right so as opposed to
drawing something which is called a
global state transition diagram which
you will find in the literature where
they tell you for any conceivable
possible state what your modifications
of these counter values are going to be
ok so the two things you need to do is
get rid of the 0 value counters and
store separate state sets for each
program location that's something that
any explicit state model checker would
certainly do in any symbolic model
checker would likely do as well that you
would have separate symbolic
representations for the state for each
program location and that's something
you will not find any literature here ok
all of these assume that there's some
global state transition ground
okay so the savings obvious of the
slides illiterate illustrates this right
to have a vector like this with all
these zeros you can think of what
happens when you make your transition
say you change a to see okay when the
value from the counter for a gets gets
decreased in the counter for C gets
increased and what you do instead is
before you so you start out with a
vector it only contains the counter for
a accounted for be a giveaway because it
becomes zero you kick it out of your
state vector and C goes in okay actually
think this hour you should point in the
other direction should point up goes up
okay that's essentially what you need so
it requires some bookkeeping because the
position no longer tells you what you're
counting so you need to remember what
these individual positions in your stead
act or okay that's just some bookkeeping
okay so um there are a number of
problems that arise in this and again
this is a fairly low level
implementation issue in some sense okay
so what essentially we have is so
following so we have a representation
that is a cross product of some local
state and then sorry some shared state
and then some number of local states an
account a value okay that's what we are
storing all right and you're going to
use a symbolic representation for this
the reason why I've used as symbolic
representation for visits because
boolean programs have a lot of non
determinism and you cannot going to get
this non determinism ave it's actually
important because of the abstraction or
in order to be sound okay so this is
going to stay and you need to handle it
and the only way to handle this non
determinism is by means of some symbolic
representation okay so now what kind of
symbolic representation can be actually
used in this context so what we
experimenting with is to have separate
BDDs to each one of these so we have a
BDD but it represents the shared state
all right and we have separate BDDs for
each one of these local components
oh yeah that's executive of this slide
is about okay so how do you encode
correlations so before we get into how
we do for correlations let me first
discuss the alternative option which is
that one you to pee dee dee for
everything alright in which it's very
easy to capture a connection between
this and say that okay okay yeah it's
not good enough because the BDDs get
very large and ugly ok B it is this a
bit of magic right and a good BDD is a
BDD but talks about few things all right
and so this was actually an
implementation we had tried so we had
implemented all this story with a global
BDD okay i will tell you why it's not
really working out first of all it's a
BD diva talks about a lot of arable
that's always bad and second remember
that we we need to keep the state
vectors canonical okay and that in
particular means that we need to come up
with some ordering of these ok so a
always has to be before B & B is to be
before see if we start having an
arbitrary ordering of these when these
vectors are no longer canonical all
right when the same set can be
represented by two different data
structures and that will make my fix my
detection really hard and all sorts of
other bad things and so what I would
have to do in this scenario is i will
need to rename these in the order of
these local states but remember these
local states are represented by a BDD
okay and so I would need to compare BDDs
sub BDDs inside a big ability and
according to this need to shuffle it
around and that means i need to reorder
vbd these variables in order to shuffle
these around and that the complexity of
our operation depends on the distance
inside the BDD vector and that's
unfortunately a very expensive and
complex operation and one that doesn't
work well at all now so so it turned out
that this is this was approached with
with a lot of pain that took us a year
to figure it out with a lot of pain we
figure out that this global BDD that
represents a shared space the local
States all-in-one BDD but didn't work
out for us you put a lot of work in
trying to research better ways of
changing
durable orderings and so on and you
never worked very well okay so that's
why we ended up with having separate
BDDs full of these which has the
advantage that these separate abilities
are small because they only talk about
few variables ordering them is very easy
because p dds can easily be compared
it's a very inexpensive operation and if
we were to swap them around it's also
inexpensive because it's a constant time
operation to swap around the fire
separate beauties if they're if it's one
BD D it's really really really expensive
and now it's constant time okay right so
the question that remains is what if i
have a statement that establishes some
sort of connection between say a share
variable & local variable but you could
have the same question about what
happens if i have a connection between
two Fred's in some sense that they have
agree on on some variable or something
like this ok how do we do this right if
it's a separate BDD where isn't really
any way to express this unless these are
constants right so it can say here but X
is true and I can hear we say here that
some local variables true when they
agree on it but if I want to say it's
evil one of true or false but the same
in both when there isn't really any way
of doing this right it's very clear yeah
so here we have an example for this so
this is a state vector so we have two
threads in which some local variable is
0 and you say suppose we don't know
anything about this the value of this
global variable here yeah and then
suppose I assign the global variable to
BL so that's not problematic at all
because here i'm copying a constant so
this this global variable or shared
variable which is become 0 and the local
herbal just 80 ok this is just fine this
scenario ok this is no problem at all
but what if the local variable wasn't
defined before ok so it's a
non-deterministic chosen value so this
can represent any value here sorry Colin
tool just means remember up here at the
local state and this is a counter value
this means there are two threads in this
okay all right and by the way so this
means there are two Fred's would agree
on that value yeah all right so if I did
this so if I just copy the star over
that's obviously wrong right because
then that just means that they are
really the cross product of always write
this what does the local state it is
equal to starving but it's either 0 of 1
right it's not the Sun initialized or it
comes out of a non-deterministic choice
where I'm reading it as that for each
state there's the number of threads you
know right so it is equal to start
calling to means what it means that
there are two threads act l is equal to
0 and 2 30 is equal to 1 yes but they
agree so it's the same state but you're
not saying whether it's zero of one but
both of these threads on the same state
so this represents really how many oh
yeah good question how many states does
this really represent here altogether
this represents four states right
because you have a choice for the global
variable and if a choice for this local
variable all right and the fact that
they're two of em just doesn't increase
it just means the vector is a bit wider
ok all right so the point is I can no
longer just copy it over because
officials copy over that star it doesn't
actually change your vector but it
should because now where is the
connection between these variables and
that needs to be represented somehow all
right so what I unfortunately need to do
in this case is a need to split all
right so this means i need to make a
commitment as to these two cases of l
being 0 I'll being one I need to branch
up this non deterministic choice at this
point and then it's clear how to do this
right so it's just two V's two cases
separately and I just told you that if
it's a constant it's no problem at all
all right so I just played it up and
when i get these two cases in which s0
and s1 and the corresponding local
variable has the same value all right so
that's no problem at all once i split it
up all right
sir the culantro is number of friends
the number of threads in that particular
local sadness to threats yes and that's
worthy
where they go prepare and but they have
to be the same exam yes that's right so
now I don't think of your representation
earlier was a conjunction of local very
dangerous now it's at this junction of
such fun penny auctions oh yes when you
split so neither this LBJ disjunction of
conjunction abilities that's right yes
exactly so this but whenever you have
something on the way I'm going I'm going
to get to exactly the condition in which
I split shape before that it is so can
any set of states be represented as a
disjunction of conjunction of local
communities yes in the worst case you
numerate so this is the new drama comes
in bali encoding too much more explicit
here yes it's a bit of a hybrid oh yeah
oh yeah we just vote at the end over it
yes that's allowed you know don't be
like a fullness job yes yeah so a one
thing that I didn't mention I'm not
gonna mention it again was just a born a
pointed out this also opportunities for
merging again okay so I'm not just let
this disjunction grow but at some point
I might also realize hey I can throw
these two things together there are some
conditions for doing so okay and you
need to be careful to to remain
canonical when you do these sort of
things and not over proximate is very
easy to over to mistakenly over
approximate singles modulate your logic
and easy
no so because you just keep this list of
discounts and you can just do a pair of
eyes comparison so it just gets a bit
more compared very expensive to do a
fixed point detection but it's still
canonical okay just slightly more
complex all right so versa formalization
of this property and the cold with this
situation in which you have
communication between a local and a
global variable a splice state all right
and this is simply the formal definition
of what of splice state is and they
always result from communication between
threads okay you can always use this as
a definition of convert communication
between threads is but they create spice
stats and something that doesn't create
a splice state is in communication all
right so we kind of syntactically you
can tell which kind of statements can
put use this so where it needs to be
some communication between some local
and some proper variable all right and
whenever you execute these you just
simply do a Shannon expansion and split
up all right and now one question that's
obvious to be asked here is you know
isn't are you going to be punished for
this because there's ops ops obviously
potential for exponential growth here
all right and the answer is as follows
so this works because on real-world
booming programs are relatively few of
these by statements only twelve percent
of the statements we found in real-world
boolean programs can syntactically
generate in a generator splice so the
others are unable to produce a splice
state syntactically already okay and
furthermore so one thing you will notice
here that this is worst-case exponential
in the number of variables that are
involved in this splice state but in
practice were very few splice variables
in these few splice statements so in
practice is usually just one only in
very few cases to all right so that
means that this is contained at only
very few real word States whether
reachable so it depends on what states
are reachable actually require a
duplication of your state vector only
ten percent all right so twelve percent
of instructions
can potentially splice and of these only
ten percent do so it's really about a
percent of instruction but is doing the
communication and where you actually
need to do a splitting right and as I
said reverse the opportunity to merge
back again right it's one thing which is
critical in practice here is to keep the
program counter separate in these state
vectors because obviously otherwise
everything would be a splice statement
if you merge it all into one huge magic
monster statement all right hard oh yes
exactly it's part of that no it's not
according to the BDD is kept separately
also you have a GF an explicit is it yes
programs take a break yes yes all right
that's something very common actually I
mean most most monitors for software
regresar okay so let me get to
experimental evidence by this is useful
ok so we're analyst on any boolean
program we could get our hands on and I
have a student who got a job this time
in 22 neck anybody knows and we ever
talked about booting programs for for
mobile programs okay so we have files so
many concurrent billion program I can't
believe that there are a few boolean
programs out there whatever concurrent
Williams so we did before him so we be
next Byron and the constructed some from
slam benchmarks with some effort to
identify what is initialization and what
is actually a code was supposed to run
in concurrently and we made a harness
that specifically creates fred's for
linux device drivers so essentially it's
meant to mimic what slam does for
windows your eyes forever in the case of
linux device drivers and there is great
care taken to actually separate
initialization routines from the actual
code and then again at the end clean up
code okay so that we carefully separate
out what is meant to run concurrently
from body's meant to run sequentially
dispatch routine that you running at the
same time oh well I'm going to get to
this right so what you see actually here
so this answers your question to some
extent okay just right the risk
communication between these oh yeah sure
by communicate if not when the whole
thing is very trivial yeah all right no
no we're yeah I mean we sent twelve
percent of sliced agency to come from
somewhere right so if you if you have if
i have destroyed if i only have local
variables on that while it would be zero
okay so uh so this is a scatter plot and
normally in scatter plots you have like
dots or crosses but here you have
numbers okay so if you if you don't see
them you can just come a little bit
closer and you see whether lots of
little numbers here on this scatter plot
all right so the number is actually the
number of frets over a number of
dispatch routines but that's operating
okay so you see lots of little tools
some fours fives and some sevens eights
okay and there's a big black bar here
okay sir yes did you model it currently
running dispatch routine so did you also
model asynchronously generated
completion routines or cancellation or
you know TPC dyess are those kinds of
things there's also in in the key in the
case of a linux routine sir we had some
more expertise on what is going on they
also had an interrupt service handler
and he also had the equivalent of what
linux would I guess call cancellation
yes there is also a clean up routine
that tries to wait for Fred's it run and
so then you remove a module these
examples you actually did have control
dependent creation of threads we have
seven a sickness
all right ok back to this scatterplot
all right so these little numbers you
know the number of threads running okay
and so this is comparing our symbolic
model checking if this counter
abstraction against a plane symbolic
explorations out this abstraction okay
and so whenever the number is above this
diagonal and this means our algorithm
Vince and whenever it's below and the
traditional method twins okay so it's
easy to see that all but the vast
majority of numbers is above the line
and another thing you will see if you go
really really close to to to to the
screen is that above the line you only
find tues okay yes please Nancy break
exploration web media could you use one
after the other or attorney with
interesting cables interleaved actually
that's good because that's that's the
project the most promising yeah so we
put a lot of work and trying to find out
BDD verbal orders and obviously future
was working at nine so what efficient
simberg I mean be debased square
acknowledges its partition transition
relations by a masculine version long
etc so that's why I'm yeah so we also
use a fairly sophisticated BDD library
but tries to do a dynamic reordering and
ov sort of things so we put some amount
of work into into getting the our
comparison work so one data point I can
also contribute is but for the
sequential case of having just one fret
its performance is very much comparable
with that of bebop okay so it's not
completely crap that's what I'm trying
to say no I mean with no no it's a vest
a lot of magic in Middle East and it's
you know a committee a grievous a lot of
magic abilities and since we're we
created the comparison point it's it's
fair to ask you know the thing you're
comparing with is that maybe it's just
plain dumb right so what I'm trying to
claim is that the comparison point is
not playing dumb because you put a lot
of work and optimizing it and it
compares bell with with other
implementations at least level
think that is below the line yes if if
instantiate it on that thing with single
thread is competitive with bball that's
why significant years and right that's
pretty good so another thing we compared
against is is smv and it also compares
parable the fat but that's a bit unfair
because it's envious of fictional
optimized for this case right but it
means it's not completely dumb right and
another thing we did is we also made an
explicit state version of this which I
unfortunately didn't bring the slide for
and compare it against Murphy okay so
Murphy was handle two mice but somebody
really knows about symmetry reduction
and we sort of things okay so obviously
Murphy isn't able to deal with a data
and with non determinism but if you if
you take bullion programs to reduce data
non-determinism then you can make a fair
comparison of murphy against a version
of this algorithm its explicit state all
right and and our algorithm also
compares very favorably against Murphy
in the Senate yeah obviously you are not
comparing the symbolic version against
Murphy that would be again on sir but
they're comparing an explicit state
version of our grew from against Murphy
okay all right so let me point out some
more properties of this graph here so
one thing you will notice is that the
very high numbers tend to be very much
in this corner so the higher the number
of threats the more we gain all right
and particularly you'll see that these
are actually very much here this means
you actually see sequences of numbers
that are staying on this side and you
increase the thread count and you hardly
pay any price in terms of extra
computational time right and this is in
some sense intuitively right because
this whole counter abstraction just
lives from merging identical freight
fred's if there are only two threads
around then the best you can always get
is is that what verse f1 Fred count of
it has we value to ok that's the best
you can hope for it so is not much
potential for a reduction but if there
are eight Fred's around then obviously
there is much more potential for being
in the same local state and you can save
much more all right so that's why this
is not actually very surprising but the
high ever afraid account gets the better
our algorithm compares against three
alternatives alright so one thing which
is also important is that this you
blob of black here which is all numbers
and actually a very vast majority of
these programs for any Fred pound that's
not tools is really only solvable with
our counter abstraction and it's not
solvable by playing symbolic exploration
so it's really enabling it makes a big
difference in terms of the number of
benchmarks you get through in some time
out ok all right so this is by the way
up to this point this is what was
presented a cab this year and I'm now
going to switch to a part which wasn't
yet presented a car okay so oh yeah
before I get to this here's the URL if
you want to download this and try with
yourself this has a bsd license so it's
not cheap ale so Microsoft employees are
very much authorised by so there's no
legal constraint that would prevent you
from from trying out this code ok let me
just measure that so so now I want to
get to his question all right so doing
this for some number of threads is fine
but what he really really want this to
case in which where you have some loop
it can spawn threads dynamically advil
right and you don't want to commit a
priori what kind of number of Fred's
that would be all right and so remember
that we had this case of and that and
now it actually really becomes important
that we have the case of of a program
with replicated threads executing the
same boolean program all right so we
have this model em that's parameterize
din some number n and so far was a
constant and now I won't end to be a
variable alright so this is called the
parameter rice system verification
problem this has been around for many
years okay and there is a paper this is
a paper virtuosa this is a general
undecidable and the proof is actually
very easy so
yes yes so
I would imagine that I would not
formulate mm-hmm the problem like this
all right I'm going to get to this I
think I'm i think i can anticipate your
question so the thing is that obviously
if you take an arbitrary family of these
sort of moles in a property p then this
is a slightly more general problem than
the problem of having boolean programs
with n Fred's with arbitrary number
before returning number first there's an
assertion is floating around and I just
want to check its on the second game
doesn't write so long you run the
program I'm gonna get to this so the
point I'm trying to make is that where
is this well-known claim but in general
parameterize purification problem is
undecidable but for this specific case
of boolean programs it actually is
decidable okay so i just wanted to
clarify this bed i'm obviously aware of
these results showing whether it's a
sunny side up and remotely aware of the
fact that this is a special case and
therefore this doesn't apply all right
yeah so boob in programs without
recursion with unbounded number of
rights are not touring complete right so
a relatively easy way to see this so it
again depends on the community you talk
to for example we talked to people at
NEC and they were surprised by this so
we were thinking of this has to be
unassailable but then if you talk to
people in the Patriot community I yeah
that's the reality right let's cover
ability also it really depends on what
community a person comes from so in
Germany for example they're Patriots are
huge everybody knows this ok but here
and yes don't you seem to be that many
people have seen this before ok so you
can sometimes surprised people like I do
this sigh I like having little service
in my lectures so I show the students
some problem like oh no I tell them blah
blah blah what if you've seen so far and
then Austin and what if I make this
number frets unbounded this is still
decidable and now try to make a majority
vote thing as to who things were versus
decidable not and usually there's a
clear majority for this being
undecidable alright so in no matter
where I try this ok so the argument by
business decidable is that you can
rewrite booting programs into vector
dition systems and verses are fairly
ancient result that but the explains
woodcarver ability where is decidable
and the argument is is evolving to have
it that you can use a procedure called
the carp military to produce a tree a
conservatory of states but the system
could be in ok and the only thing you
will need to see is as to why a boolean
program is really expressible as a
vector addition system and to see that
I'm going to illustrate what r vector
addition system is so in a vector
addition system you have states so we
have free states here that's meant to be
an initial state that's why it's labeled
with I and there are two states here
which are used to distinguish your value
of some sherry variable and together
with these these states you have vectors
of integers with integers are
potentially unbounded all right and they
can be manipulated by means of adding or
subtracting these constant numbers to
them ok so this means increase the first
counter ok and this means don't change
it this means decrease the first one
increase the second ok and this means
decrease the second increase referred ok
so these are not as expressive as
counter machines for which you would
already have undecidability for two
counters because you can't really
compare so you can't do relational
operations on these counters all right
so well so the question is you know how
do we actually get a vector addition
system from one of these moving programs
so the trick here is again essentially
the same idea we did before to get the
symmetry reduction so we count how many
local states they are if you use these
counters in the vector addition system
in order to keep track of this right so
for example if you were to make a
transition if we were to execute the
statement here number one in which is
set variable one variable s to true and
suppose we come from a state in which
its false we simply need to increase the
V appropriate counter for that
particular local state all right so
actually this
vector addition system down here is
meant to purrs and this little boolean
program here alright and actually did
have a master student whose job was to
take a boolean program and translate it
exactly into this form okay so a one
catch that you have here obviously is
the following you run again into the
same problem that we had before namely
that you actually need to have a one of
these entries in your vector for every
conceivable local state and remember the
number of local states is exponential
the number of local variables in your
bullying program and this means we're
too many all right so our contribution
here is again similar to what you have
seen before you don't even ever built
the vector addition system explicitly
but you in some sense need to
intermingle the exploration of your
state space with a construction of a
vector addition system itself and the
trick is again to not even ever store 0
counters now you can do the same trick
if for the case of a vector addition
system all right another problem that
pops up here is that if you look at this
original construction by carp millers
but it has a non primitive recursive
space complexity which is a really bad
news they exists improvement that you
can find in your literature that makes
this X space complete but it's still
pretty bad all right really bad news I
mean normally we deal with just with
pspace complete friends okay so we still
have implemented vez all right and with
a number of optimizations such as not
storing the zero counters and so on and
this is what you get so this is this
axis is benchmarks okay sorted by the
time it takes to compute the set of
states reachable with an unbounded
number of threats and this is run time
in seconds okay so this is one second
here so you can see the vast majority of
e is solvable within one second and this
is for an unbounded number of threads
alright obviously this problem of
complexity hits us at some point so
there exists some number of benchmarks
which are simply too hard for us right
now for with this procedure all right
it's a fairly small number of these you
simply have a loop and the loop contains
a start Fred command and so you need at
least from that device drivers ah yes
the same thing incredible dispatch
machines we in fact which is the same
set of benchmarks for both problems only
that on in the first case with bounded
number of threats we simply stop
creating Fred's after some time now
after for some number friends have been
created ok these were the same age 4 is
the same benchmarks yes so because
before you didn't visit the absolute
number silicon verizon be rigorous
sophistication oh no baby this is kind
of broad shows up tube number i miss
that that's seconds so this is the one
second so what you can see is that the
carburetor is actually faster in many
cases so we computed the place where
they have the same speed like how many
Fred's do you need for the for the
boundary case to get the same time run
time roughly the same run time as the
Carmelo procedure and the observer it in
many cases the number is something that
one or two meaning in some in many cases
it's actually the case with exploring
the set of reachable States when I model
number of Fred's is exactly as expensive
as exploring a set of reachable frights
for one Fred okay right so as I said
this there are cases that are too hard
for this yeah it's not the final answer
to this but for many real-world programs
you get a very inexpensive answer as to
what receptive reachable Fred States is
for an unbounded number of threads all
right
okay so let me conclude this works for
arbitrarily many frets no more question
about whether you're just need one more
friend to get the back okay this does
handle dynamic recreation you know the
control flow dependent if you want okay
is precise so this is not an over
proximate it's not an under
approximation alright what is missing is
recursion but at least for our
experience that with the device revis is
there is usually no interesting with
Persian happening all right thank you
question yes so I'm still trying to
understand like what kind of my current
programs are coming you said its drivers
mostly right so one thing I equity match
marriage has problems easy in parallel
computations that you have an eight-way
barrier between friends it seems
immediately that it would need to model
the counter to have you know besides we
are you something very special I
strongly suspect but you could come up
with something in this set it set up but
would implement the barrier without
using a counter right so you essentially
would not consider it a result the bat
in the barrel you have like threats a
threats do something concurrently and
vinay all
I evading proprietor so you would have
some captain count that counts how many
have reached yes it's of a normal way of
implementing a barrier is that you are
aware of how many Fred's they are this
would be some global variable and it
would obviously depend on the number of
threads that are running which doesn't
really fit this model because there's no
way here to find out how many Fred's are
all your dog is specifically about the
incident thread case it's also problem
public or in parallel programs that will
launch exactly eight threads you know
initialize the country to have been
operating and you'll make for those big
threats to yeah so what my answer to
this is that likely what you want here
is the equivalence of a barrier in the
boolean program but you are able to do
this while you explore because then it
becomes actually fairly easy right you
simply don't consider transitions but
cross the barrier while we are still
Fred's but do not yet adverb area
because that's a control flow properties
in 3d data ok I think yeah so you can
coat the barrier somehow directly yes it
had a very similar observation so if you
if you push with the concept of a
lockdown into a boolean program you can
get much bigger much better precision as
opposed to trying to model it the
boolean variables and second yeah one
reason is one simple observation at
various is because there's obviously
that doesn't exist a shared state in
which you have two threads that have a
lock right so this is something you even
know you can rule out and you don't ever
need to consider yeah so meaning there's
probably some case for having some of
these concurrency primitives like
barriers or locks down at the level
moving programs as opposed to trying to
replicate them with boolean variables
make the case of a counter to get the
barrier is certainly a strong argument I
mean you would have to emulate this with
some stupid boolean variables and it'll
certainly cost you this is very good
actually why how could you have not done
done that already to have a very end
there I mean you have all these second
eyes I have lost in the in the yeah you
should probably be done so one put shall
be probably do some thinking as to what
the most needed concurrency primitives
are and add them to two boolean programs
because handling these in the model
checker during expiration is is fairly
inexpensive main causes some
implementation
work but it doesn't add any complexity
all right but including visas boolean
variables is likely going to be pricey
all right so that's my answer to this if
you put it into boolean variables it's
likely not going to work very well but
if you put it into a boolean program as
a as a specific primitive and I don't
see any reason why I children work mmm
all right yep okay so I'm not just
struggling this is the applicability
basically and we in my mind I don't know
if you agree with that but the reason
why symmetry reduction hasn't had that
big impact in mah jackee hunger me it's
because it's very rare it's very hard to
find really symmetric system somewhere
and so it's a now one key question is
that through abstraction can have more
symmetry we have Stephanie the
Christians and the second thing is like
well like you mentioned Murphy's open
when Murphy is probably up here we
perhaps one tool that leverage to post
basically it has the most compelling
application domain for this symmetry
degenerate was this cash branch particle
right you have lots of symmetries due to
data symmetry entity all right so now
inputting programs themselves there's no
data symmetry but now you can also think
of all the type of perhaps or Richard of
recycled interaction when you still
capture these symmetries and be able to
take advantage of this type of
individual I don't know if you agree
with my overall assessment first at
about like broken coffee so far the
bankruptcy buddy sorry about seemed a
fee reduction and second I mean I you
have you thought more about how
abstractions I mean the interaction
symmetry and abstraction all right okay
let me begin with the first point
interaction between symmetry and
abstraction I mean there's obviously a
case here by the fact that we could use
the predicate abstraction we're
certainly many more symmetries in the
abstract model when you find in the
original model all right so if you
consider the concrete state of the
original model with things like variable
adversities pointers or contain these
variable addresses and so on it's
clearly the case with these frets simply
are not symmetric in the original
program we are not symmetric they only
become symmetric by doing the data
attraction
alright and that things like addressees
in pointers jusco of a all right that's
the certainly important here I would
certainly not expect this sort of
reduction on the original mortgage in
many cases I mean when Craig attraction
works because you can wear these things
in some cases and it's harder than you
have to refine it said why do you
realize that these abstraction very long
so now the symmetries you can bring the
synergy there I mean the nice thing
about your framework is that the model
checking parties you didn't discuss how
the abstraction the breakers are in and
the energy I packed on the refinery of
the process the abstraction refinement
you make them terminal right I wonder
some cases well the answers but if you
were typing more yes so the answer is
probably the same as to why predicate
abstraction works to begin the okay so
predicate abstraction doesn't work
everywhere and I don't expect a
particular section to work in more
places just because we have concurrency
in there okay if anything will work in
fewer places same thing with symmetry in
this case right so meaning predica
abstraction is only good for specific
types of properties and the same case
holes here so meaning the usual kind of
control flow dominated properties now
that's the sort of stuff where I expect
this to work very well and a belief it's
fair to say that for these sort of
examples these sort of properties you
also observe a lot of symmetry in the
abstract model okay so this works for
specific types of properties not for
arbitrary data properties in particular
so our question I know about the
scoundrel abstraction as an instance
tree right I soon will see what is the
connection of symmetry woodworking
presented County obstruction is a
specific instance of a symmetry
reduction all right maybe one that takes
care of this permutation symmetry where
you permute a vector of off states and
so it's a specific instance of a
symmetry reduction we're obviously many
other symmetry reductions encounter
attraction is one of them I guess I
always thought leader kind of symmetry
ten more feet of cement sure that should
maybe I yes it's a different kind of of
symmetry reduction all right so one
thing more thing to say about Murphy is
that Murphy didn't work for a long this
all right so in fact our experiments
show that that the counter abstraction
works much better on the sort of worker
than one not Murphy is doing ok so this
was obviously comparing two different
kinds of symmetry reduction but we
wanted to see what happens you compare
visible for mature implementation of for
submitting reduction all right if I baby
Surya reiterated that for the comparison
with the experimental comparison with
Murphy yes it was not using goes
bare-faced explicit so it was not
symbolic versus explicit no it was
explicit versus exclusive obviously yes
so what you're basically specific
encoding yes so you can obviously make
an explicit say version of 10 questions
right okay so one more point I want to
make a maybe that could be the final
point is but so you decided that there's
some bad history on on using symmetry
reductions in the case for software in
some sense especially symbolic
representations so one thing which we
found a little bit odd is for falling so
we haven't actually been that many
reports of success using things like
partial order reduction in a symbolic
setting wouldn't you agree with it right
and one thing we tried why Sir well
because of that work of efficient
transition relation friends in 90s which
give you the same effect but it doesn't
doesn't reduce the state space but it
gives you a manageable or so they saw
the plan for a manageable state space
representation see buddy state space
representation for asynchronous sister
all right so we found this discussion a
little bit unsatisfactory so we were a
little bit disappointed that there's so
little research on on partial or
reduction in the symbolic setting right
so one thing that you did is to try this
so this is a version of our tool but
just implements partial reduction it's
not obvious how you do partial order
doctrine in a symbolic setting but it is
actually doable like you read the paper
you get an idea how this is done
symbolically and you agree that this is
how it's likely to be done okay like all
of these things like recycling dish and
all these tests you just need to
implement okay and this is what you get
as a result so one thing you do see that
even though we're so quite some blob
year of fat black there's also some
numbers here so you won't think we argue
is that there isn't actually a clear
winner here between a partial reduction
and counter abstraction okay like a
partial a reduction against a plane
exploration even with this disjunctive
partitioning Vince clearly so there is a
benefit of using partial or reduction
okay even in a symbolic settings so I
disagree with the statement that you've
just made just from our experimental
observations the benefit is huge it's
not just a little bit okay but one thing
we did observe is where there is
actually an even better story so if you
compare yes what was that it was nasty
should be specific search cydia
satisfaction partition room five years
which is not the standard breadth-first
search that right okay so that's just
that's all right so maybe this was a
very specific so in any case we found
partially yeah rest so in any case what
we I think it's fair to say but this
wasn't really looked into properly in a
broader setting I think there's very few
papers on this at all and there are a
few people ever implemented partial
reduction in a symbolic model checker
okay it's certainly well understood for
explicit save model checkers and there's
a lot of literature on this hundreds of
papers right
very few papers in the case of symbolic
analysis and one thing we did find is
that it helps a lot really and as you
see we found it to have comparable
performance with our counter abstraction
so what we've ended is to implement the
combination of our account abstraction
and partial or reduction be to actually
combine and this is something you do
find in the literature normally you read
the literature and you find the claim
that symmetry plus partial or reduction
goes well together okay and you found
that to be true for the symbolic case as
well so if you take the partial
reduction enter counter example let's
check you get a tool that's yet another
order of magnitude faster then just too
plain County abstraction itself okay so
and and it's tyrannically faster than
just partial or reduction by itself
alright so we to go very very well
together and it's not the case that one
obsoletes we offer okay thank you well
and one more question yeah no we didn't
try with some cash for instance hello
it's very similar stuff has been done on
no we didn't try this on cash for
Koreans coracles at all I don't think
they even thought about it